in this video we're going to go through
an Algebra 2 second semester final exam
review we're going to go through 55
questions step by step we're going to go
through the formulas we're going to talk
about how to solve these problems you
might want to pause the video and try to
do these problems on your own and then
go ahead and go over them together with
me to see how you did let's dive into
the first example so the first problem
it says ten thousand dollars is invested
at three percent
compounded continuously in how many
years will it be worth fifteen thousand
dollars so go ahead and pause the video
see how you would do that problem the
key here with this question is you
really want to know this formula a
equals p e to the RT power this is when
you're compounding continuously the p is
the principal in this case that's going
to be the ten thousand dollars invested
e is our natural base e it's about 2.7
you can use that e uh button on your
calculator R is the rate but you want to
make sure you convert that percentage
into a decimal by moving that decimal
point two places to the left so that's
going to make this point zero three and
then the T here is the time in years
which that's what we're trying to solve
for is the ending amount which is the
fifteen thousand dollars
okay so now how can we solve for this
variable T well let's go ahead and
divide both sides by 10 000. so if we do
that
we're working from the outside in
towards this variable T here
that gives us 1.5 equals e to the .03 T
now what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to take the natural log of both
sides natural log remember we don't see
it but that's understood to be base e so
if I take the natural log or the log
base e of both sides the log base C and
this exponential function base either
inverses of one another they undo each
other and you're just left with .03
times T and so now we have natural log
of 1.5 all we have to do is divide by
0.03 to get the time by itself if you do
that to the right you want to do that to
the left and let's go to the calculator
now let's see what we get we've got
natural log of 1.5
divided by .03 and I'm getting about
13.5 years so we'll just say
approximately
13.5 years okay good so for number two
how would you do this one four thousand
dollars is invested at an annual
interest rate of 4 percent
find the balance after 10 years if it is
compounded monthly so go ahead and pause
the video see how you would do that
problem the key here with this question
is to really know this formula a equals
P 1 plus r Over N to the NT power so
this is when you're compounding like
daily or weekly or monthly or this pert
formula right here this is when your
compounding continuously that's the key
word in that problem so how would you do
this one now if I was going to do it I
would start with the p the principal
which is the four thousand dollars and
we know that our interest rate is four
percent so that's going to be point zero
four as a decimal n is the number of
times you're compounding in a year
monthly means that'd be 12 times in a
year this n in this Center the exact
same value so that's going to be 12 as
well and we want to know how much you're
going to have after 10 years so if we go
ahead and put this in our calculator we
can find out the ending amount after 10
years so this let's go ahead and do that
you can do it in steps if you want like
do the parentheses and then raise it to
120th power and then multiply by four
thousand make sure you follow that order
of operations or that PEMDAS
uh but I'm just going to go ahead and
put it all in in one step here on this
graphing calculator and this is coming
out to 5000
963 dollars and 33 cents remember you
always want to go to the two decimal
places the hundreds that's your pennies
and you got it okay see if you can pause
the video and do these four problems for
the first two what we're going to do is
we're going to write in either
exponential or logarithmic forms we're
going to basically be changing forms so
if it's in log form right in exponential
form and vice versa so for number three
how would you do this one log base 2 of
32 is 5 or equals 5. how would you
rewrite that not in log form but
exponential form
there's a lot of different ways that
teachers explain this the way that I
like to think about it I think the way
that is most intuitive is instead of log
base 2. let's go ahead and
exponentiate or raise both sides using
base two what this does is you've got an
exponential function and a logarithmic
function and because you're
exponentiating and the bases are the
same
these are inverses of one another they
undo each other and now look what we
have 2 to the fifth power is equal to
32. that's your exponential form now you
can flip it if you want and write it
like this 2 to the fifth power equals 32
and you got it so that's one way to do
these problems a number number four
let's look at this one we've got three
to the fifth equals 243 how do we write
this in logarithmic form
the way that I like to do it is because
this is an exponential function with
base 3 how about if we do the inverse
which is to take the log base 3 of both
sides of the equation we're keeping it
balanced the log base 3 and the
exponential function base 3 those undo
each other they're inverses like
squaring and square rooting or
multiplying and dividing and so now you
can see look what we're left with 5 is
equal to log base 3 of 243. you could
also flip it if you wanted if you want
the log here on the left
and now you can see you've got it in the
logarithmic form if you want to check
your work you can just undo this you can
say oh this is log base 3 let me
exponentiate or raise both sides using
base 3 and you'll see that you're going
to get back to what our original you
know you get basically they're undoing
one another okay so good job if you got
those number five and number six without
using a calculator evaluate which means
find the value of log base 3 of 1 over
81 and log base 8 of 1. so go ahead and
pause the video see if you can do these
two problems if I was going to do this I
would use this technique here a lot of
students like this they set it equal to
like a variable say like axis is like
our unknown and then I would do very
similar to what we're doing here I would
rewrite it in exponential form so I
would say Okay log base 3 let me
exponentiate or raise both sides using
base three these are inverses they undo
one another now all I have to do is
figure out 3 to what power equals 1 over
81. well I know know that 3 to the
fourth power is 81 but you can see this
is 1 over 81 so that means this is going
to be 3 to the negative fourth power
remember a negative exponent tells us to
take the reciprocal and you got it for
number six same idea log base 8 of 1
okay so I'm going to exponentiate using
base eight so I'm going to raise both
sides using base 8 these are inverses of
one another they undo each other all I
have to do now is figure out eight to
what power equals one of course anything
to the zero power is equal to one so
this is just going to be equal to zero
and you got it okay so let's go on to
number seven now it says find the domain
and the range of y equals log base 3 of
x minus 2. a couple different ways to do
this problem go ahead and pause the
video and see if you can do it a quick
way to do this is that we know that we
can't take the log of a zero or a
negative quantity so whatever is in this
parenthesis here has to be greater than
zero so an easy way to do this is just
say x minus 2 is greater than zero add 2
to both sides X is greater than 2 that's
your domain so that's an easy way to do
it another way to do it is if you know
what logarithmic graphs look like
which is like this where they approach
that y-axis the x minus 2 what's grouped
with the X has the opposite effect here
the minus 2 is Shifting it right two so
what would happen now is that your new
vertical asymptote instead of being at
the y-axis is going to shift right to
and your graph's going to look like that
so it's going to be from 2 to infinity
or you could say x is greater than 2.
now if you wanted to do the range you
can see the graph is going down forever
and ever gradually up forever and ever
the range is going to be all real
numbers
so that's your domain and range now for
number eight see if you can do this one
it says evaluate using the change of
Base formula and we've got log base 4 of
11. so go ahead and pause the video see
if you can do that one remember the
change of Base formula that's an easy
way of evaluating logs if you have a
calculator that doesn't have the ability
to change the base like some calculators
you can change the base to whatever you
want some calculators just have log base
10 and natural log so what I'm going to
do here is I'm going to take the log of
11 divided by the log of 4 or you could
do like the natural log of 11 over the
natural log of 4 what you don't want to
do is do the log of 11 4 or the natural
log of 11 4. so you have to do log of
11.
divided by the quantity log of 4 or
natural log 11 over natural log of 4.
let's go ahead and do this on the
calculator
and see what we get I'm getting
let's see I'm getting approximately 1.73
okay for number nine and number 10 see
if you can do these These are involving
expanding and condensing logarithms and
so for this first one number nine how
would you do this one you want to expand
it as a sum or difference of logs and
for number 10 you want to condense this
just into one log with base 3. so if I
was going to do this for number nine
what I would notice is that I'm dividing
here right and I'm also multiplying see
I've got 2 times x to the fifth five
times x cubed remember when you multiply
you write it as the sum of logs when you
divide you write it as a difference so
let's start off by doing that we're
going to say natural log
of 2 plus natural log of x to the fifth
now divided by so minus the quantity
natural log of 5. notice these are
multiplied together plus the natural log
of x cubed
now what you can do you can use this
power rule which says that if you have
an exponent you can bring it down in
front of that log or natural log so I'm
going to bring down these two exponents
in front and simplify so this is going
to come out to natural log of 2 plus 5
natural log of x I'm going to distribute
this negative in here so that's going to
be minus natural log of 5. minus 3
natural log of x and now it's fully
expanded if you want to check your work
you can try reversing these steps like
go ahead and bring up the 5 as a power
the 3 is a power that's the power
property and if you add you would
multiply the arguments together and if
you subtract you're going to divide any
of the logs where you're subtracting
that quantity is going to go in the
denominators okay so notice how the 5x
cubed is in the denominator and those
logs are subtracted
let's go to number 10 now so for number
10 we're condensing so with condensing
what I would do is I would take this
coefficient here
and I would bring it up as a power so
that's the first step okay oops so one
over here so if I do that this is going
to become log base 3 of x squared
minus log base 3 of 16 to the one-half
Power Plus log base 3 of 5. now when you
think of the one-half power remember the
one-half power is like the square root
if it's the one-third power it's the
cube root one fourth power the fourth
root so this is really like the square
root of 16 which is four so let's keep
that in mind okay this is actually going
to reduce down to four
okay so now let's go ahead and simplify
a little bit further remember how I said
the logs that are positive or added
you're going to multiply the arguments
the ones that are subtracted you're
going to be dividing by that argument so
what this comes out to is you've got log
base 3 of 5 times x squared
divided by 4 because we're subtracting
that log so that's your condensed
version now again if you want to check
your work you can expand it and you're
going to get back that original problem
okay see if you can pause the video and
do these next four problems on your own
it's a solve without using a calculator
so see you can do these by hand number
11 you can see we've got 5 to the X
power equals 1 over 25 to the x minus
three how would you solve that one
well here are the key to solving this
problem is really to get the bases to be
the same so you can say well what base
is common between both of these sides of
the equation looks like we can get them
to be both base five I know 1 25th is
the same as 5 to the negative 2 power
because 5 squared is 25 and the negative
we take the reciprocal and then what do
you do when you have a power raised to
another Power well power to power we
multiply these exponents together so I'm
going to distribute and that's going to
give us negative 2x Plus 6. equals 5 to
the X power now we have the bases the
same we can set the exponents equal to
each other and we can solve so x equals
negative two X plus six I'm going to add
the negative 2x to both sides so that
comes out to 3x equals 6 and if we
divide both sides by 3 we get X is equal
to 2. and if you want to check your work
you can put it back in and make sure
that both sides equal one another
for number 12 now how would you do this
one log base 4 of x equals negative 3.
well if I was going to solve this
problem I've got this log here and I
want to get this variable by itself so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
rewrite it in exponential form by
exponentiating or raising both sides
using base 4. these are inverses they
undo one another and now we're just left
with x equals 4 to the negative third
four cubed is 4 times 4 times 4 that's
64. the negative we take the reciprocal
so that's really going to be 1 over 64
and you got it
now for number 13 and 14 we've got some
log equations how would you solve these
ones
well if I was going to do number 13 what
I notice here is that these are both
natural log log base e and if you have a
log equal to a log we call this the one
to one property of logarithms we can set
these arguments equal to one another so
that means that 3x is equal to x squared
minus 10.
now all we have to do is let's subtract
3x from both sides
get everything on one side set it equal
to zero and now what we can do is we can
Factor this and set the factors to zero
so if I factor this x minus five X plus
two and if I set both of these factors
equal to zero and solve we get x minus
five equals zero X plus two equals zero
add five to both sides subtract two from
both sides we get x equals five or x
equals negative two now you wanna check
your answer if you put negative 2 in
here you get natural log of negative six
remember we can't take the log of zero
or negative quantity so this is actually
extraneous if we put 5 in we're getting
a positive a positive so this is a good
answer so in this case we just have one
solution you could have no solution two
solutions you just want to make sure
you're not taking the log of zero or a
negative
okay and then for number 14 how would
you do this problem go ahead and pause
the video
this one is kind of interesting because
we're going to actually condense this
into one log first so we've got log plus
log so when you're adding you multiply
the arguments so this is going to be log
base 2 of x times X plus 2 which is x
squared plus 2X
and then now we're going to do is going
to rewrite it in exponential form so I'm
going to exponentiate or raise both
sides using base 2. these are inverses 2
cubed is equal to 2 times 2 times 2
which is 8.
and now if we subtract 8 from both sides
and set it equal to zero we can Factor
this and solve
so we get X plus 4 x minus 2 and if we
set these factors to zero Let's see we
get X plus four equals zero so x equals
negative 4 or we get x minus two equals
zero so x equals two remember we can't
take the log of a negative quantity so
this is extraneous if we put 2 in we get
positive positive okay so this is a good
solution so again in this problem we
only got one answer okay for number 15
16 and 17 these problems you can use a
calculator on so go ahead and show your
work work through the steps and then in
the final step go ahead and use your
calculator so how would you do this
first one here 4 to the x minus 3 power
minus 6 equals 12. if I was going to
solve this problem I would work from the
outside in towards that variable X and I
would add 6 to both sides of the
equation so that's going to give us
4 to the x minus 3 power equals 18. now
because my variable is in the exponent
position I could try to get the bases to
be the same but in this case it's not
possible so what I'm going to do is
rewrite it in the logarithmic form the
easiest way that I found to think about
this is just to take the log base 4
of both sides of the equation to keep it
balanced this way the log base 4 and the
exponential function base 4 they undo
one another and we're just left with
that exponent of x minus 3 equals log
base 4 of 18. now all we have to do is
add 3 to both sides so we have x equals
3 plus log base 4 of 18. let's go to the
calculator and see approximately what
that comes out to
so I'm getting
let's see here
okay log base 4 of 18
plus 3. okay it's approximately
5.08
now for number 16 how would you do this
one this one we've got 2 times e to the
x minus 3 equals 12. again I would work
from the outside in towards that
variable by adding 3 to both sides
so that's going to give us 15 on the
right
2E to the X I would divide both sides by
2.
so now we have e to the x equals 15 over
2 and then because this is an
exponential function and that variable
is in the exponent position I want to
get that down from there get it by
itself so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take the natural log which is
like the log base C of both sides these
are inverses they undo one another and
we're left with x equals natural log of
15 halves so let's go to the calculator
on that one
and see what we're getting I'm getting
about 2.01
and then for number 17 how would you do
this one this one we've got two natural
log of the quantity 3x plus 1 minus 4
equals eight again working from the
outside in towards the variable doing
the opposite operations I'm going to add
4 to both sides
so that's equal to 12. now we have two
natural log of 3x plus one I would
divide both sides by 2 to get rid of
this 2 here
so that's going to equal 6. so the
natural log of 3x plus 1. now notice
that variable is like inside of that
logarithm so we want to get it out from
there by doing the inverse or the
opposite and I'm going to exponentiate
or raise both sides using base e
those undo one another and we're left
with three X plus one is equal to e to
the sixth
again working from the outside in I'm
going to subtract one from both sides
so that gives us three x equals e to the
sixth minus one divide both sides by
three and we've got X by itself so let's
go to the calculator see what that comes
out to
I'm getting a 134
0.14 approximately
and you got it okay see if you can do
number 18 and 19 it says does the table
show direct or inverse variation and how
would you then write the equation so a
quick uh review of direct and inverse
variation so direct variation is in the
form y equals a times x
and inverse variation is in the form y
equals a divided by X so
if you want to rearrange it though
so let's just write down here direct and
inverse okay but if you want to
rearrange it to solve for a the constant
of variation if you divide both sides by
X
see how a equals y divided by X and here
if you want to solve for a if you
multiply both sides by X
we get a equals x times y so what we're
going to do now is we're going to say
well if I multiply the X and y's
together do I get the same quantity if I
do I know it's inverse variation if I
divide the Y by the X and I get the same
constant then that tells me that it's
direct variation so let's go ahead and
do that so 1 times 3 is 3 2 times 6 is
12. 3 times 9 is 27. see we're not
getting the same number so it's not
inverse let's check direct y divided by
x 3 divided by 1 is 3 6 divided by 2 is
3 9 divided by 3 is 3 and 12 divided by
4 is 3. that tells us that it's a direct
variation
and our equation since our a we figured
out was 3 is just going to be y equals 3
times x now sometimes I like to check my
work like if I put 4 in 3 times 4 is 12
okay it checks out
for number 19 let's do that same process
so 2 times 48 is 96 4 times 24 is 96 96
96. here when we multiply the X and y's
together we're getting the same
constant so that tells us this is
inverse variation so let's write that
down inverse and we know that the
equation is going to be y equals
we said 96.
divided by X and again you can check
your work if I put 8 in here 96 divided
by 8 is 12 it checks out so that's the
key Either multiplying the X and y's
together or Y divided by X you're trying
to see if we get that same constant for
number 20 see if you can do this one go
ahead and pause the video
you want to find the domain of this
equation the range the vertical
asymptote the horizontal asymptote and
you want to graph it so go ahead and
pause the video how would you do that
one
now if I was going to do it I notice
that this is like an equation of this
form y equals a over X
but I know this H and K are shifting the
graph left and right up and down so what
this tells me is that normally when I
graph an inverse variation equation y
equals a over X if a is positive it
looks something like that if a is
negative it's reflecting over the x-axis
it looks something like that
so I know I have a vertical asymptote
and a horizontal asymptote at the axis
right but let's group with the X this is
going to shift it in the X Direction but
it's going to have the opposite effect
so x minus 2 is going to shift it right
to giving us
a vertical asymptote of x equals two
and the plus one is going to have the
same effect it's going to shift it up
one giving us a horizontal asymptote of
y equals one
and the domain we can never divide by
zero so it's going to be all real
numbers except for when X is equal to 2.
so we're just going to say all reals X
cannot be whoops I wrote it in the wrong
space all reals but X cannot be two
and then the range is going to be all
these y values except for where this
horizontal asymptote at one so we're
going to say all reals but y cannot be
one now what you can do is you can plot
some points okay usually I pick some
points on either side of this vertical
asymptote or what you can do is you can
kind of pretend like this is your new
origin and focus in on the parent
function y equals 8 over x a graph from
this point right here so that's what
I'll do I'll look at y equals 8 over X
and I'll make a table and I'll pick a
couple of negative values and a couple
of positive values so if I put in
negative 4 8 divided by negative 4 is
negative 2 8 divided by negative 2 is
negative four eight divided by 2 is 4
and 4 8 divided by 4 is 2. again
graphing from this new starting point
this shifted origin I'm going to go left
and down to
and I'm going to go left two and down
four
and so you can see this branch of the
graph looks something like
like this
okay roughly and then the other Branch
let's see if I go right to up four
right about here and right four up two
one two three four up two somewhere
right about here so this branch of the
graph kind of looks like this notice
they're getting closer and closer to
these asymptotes but they don't touch
and they don't cross so good job if
you're able to get that one
okay see if you can pause the video and
do these next four problems here what we
want to do is we want to simplify so
some of these problems you can see are
just doing a little bit of factoring
some of them you're doing some
multiplication division some you're
doing some adding or subtracting of
fractions so go ahead and pause the
video see if you can do these for number
21 the first thing I would do on this
one is I would Factor the numerator and
denominator as much as I can so here I
can see that this is going to factor the
numerator to X
and what multiplies to negative 15 but
adds to negative 2 that's negative 5 and
positive 3. in the denominator you can
see we have a difference of two squares
remember that factors as a sum and
difference pattern X plus 3 x minus 3.
now notice that X plus 3 is cancel
numerator and denominator and so we're
just left with x minus 5 divided by x
minus 3 and you got it so if you need to
review factoring I've got a factoring
video called uh you know learn how to
factor and it goes through all the
different types so check that out if
you're struggling with factoring
now for number 22 we're going to factor
this one and notice the first step in
factoring is you want to factor out a
greatest common factor so I can see I
can factor out a 2 here in the numerator
and the denominator this one's a little
bit more challenging because you have a
trinomial with the leading coefficient
it's not one you can do this a couple
different ways one is kind of like using
a trial and error method kind of like
doing the foil backwards so here I can
see negative 4 and positive 1 because
that gives me negative 4
the first terms give me the 3x squared
and the inside 1X and negative 12x adds
up to negative 11x
so here I can see that the x minus 4 is
numerator and denominator are canceling
and we're just left with two divided by
3x Plus 1.
for number 23 now we've got some
division here but what I would do is
when you divide it's like multiplying by
the reciprocal so the first some people
call this keep it change it flip it some
people hate that but you basically you
keep the first fraction the same you
change this to multiplication and you
take the reciprocal or you flip the
second fraction so for this one we can
Factor this as a difference of two
squares X plus five times x minus 5.
the denominator we've got a trinomial
with a leading coefficient of one so we
say what two numbers multiply to
negative 12 but add to negative 1 that's
negative 4 and positive 3. now I'm going
to change this to multiplication I'm
going to put the x squared minus 16 in
the numerator and that's the difference
of two squares so X plus four x minus
four
and then the denominator is going to
become the 4X minus 20 but I can factor
out a 4 as a greatest common factor now
we can reduce top and bottom top and
bottom or on the diagonals top and
bottom numerator and denominator so I
can see that this x minus 5 here cancels
I can see that this x minus 4 here
cancels top and bottom and then what I'm
going to do is I'm going to multiply
horizontally across so that's going to
be X plus 5 times X plus 4
and you can leave this in factored form
and then 4 times X plus 3 so 4 times X
plus 3. that's as far as we can go on
that one now for number 24 we're
subtracting these two fractions but
remember when you subtract fractions you
have to have the same
denominator so how can we get a common
denominator well we can see that we've
got an X plus 7 here and an x minus 2
here so X plus 7 x minus 2. let's
multiply by what we're missing so I'm
missing an x minus 2
so I'll multiply top and bottom by x
minus 2. here I'm missing an X plus 7 in
the denominator so I'll multiply the
numerator by X plus seven because that's
really like multiplying by 1 and
anything divided by itself
so now let's go ahead and simplify a
little bit we've got 2x squared minus 4X
this minus you can think of this as like
a negative 3. so I'm going to distribute
a negative 3 here that's going to give
me negative 3x minus 21 all divided by
our common denominator X plus 7 times x
minus 2. now if we just simplify a
little bit more we've got 2x squared
minus 7x combining like terms minus 21
all divided by our common denominator X
plus seven x minus two that's about as
far as you can go on that one you can
see sometimes you can Factor the
numerator further and then maybe you get
some cancellation top and bottom but
that's about as far as we can go on that
one okay see if you can pause the video
and do these next three problems
involving solving these equations these
rational equations so for 25 what would
you do on this one well notice we have a
ratio equal to ratio that's a proportion
and one way to solve proportions is just
to do the cross product so you can
multiply in the diagonal so these
multiply together equal these multiply
together so we have 3 times X plus 2
which is three X plus six
equals 7 times 2x minus 1 which is 14x
minus 7. so what we're going to do is
we're just going to subtract 3x from
both sides
and add 7 to both sides
and so that comes out to 11x equals 13
divide both sides by 11 and you can see
that X is coming out to 13 11. one thing
you want to be careful of with these
rational equations is that you want to
make sure that you don't get negative 2
or positive one half you don't want to
make sure the denominators don't come
out to zero otherwise that's going to be
an extraneous solution but in this case
we're okay
for number 26 now we have three
fractions and I think the easiest way to
solve these problems is really to get a
common denominator and multiply through
by that common denominator to clear the
denominators so when I look at the
denominators here it looks like the
common denominator is 5X so I'm going to
multiply it top and bottom here by X so
I have a denominator of 5x this one will
multiply top and bottom by 5 and this
one same here and multiply the top and
bottom by 5. so now we can see that all
of these have a denominator of 5x If I
multiply through this whole equation by
5x that clears the denominators so we're
just going to be left with the
numerators which is going to give us 2x
minus 15 equals 35. okay so basically
we're just multiplying by 5x to left and
right sides and that's clearing the
denominators that's multiplying through
by that 5x so now let's go ahead and
solve we're just going to add 15 to both
sides
that gives us 2x is equal to 50. divide
both sides by 2 and you can see we're
getting x equals 25. again checking to
make sure we're not dividing by zero
looks like this is a good solution
for 27 this one same idea we've got
three quantities here we want to get a
common denominator and multiply through
by that common denominator clear the
denominators
first thing I would do though is I'd
Factor this
into X Plus 1 x minus 1. okay so now you
can see that this fraction has a
denominator of X plus one it needs an x
minus one so it has the same denominator
but remember whatever you do to the
denominator you have to do to the
numerator so we're going to multiply the
numerator by x minus 1.
this 2 here is really like 2 over 1.
it's missing both on X Plus 1 and an x
minus 1. so we want to multiply top and
bottom by what it's missing the X Plus
1X minus 1.
so let's do that to the numerator and
the denominator but remember this is
equal to x squared minus 1. so I'm just
going to multiply the numerator by
x squared minus 1 that's the same as the
X Plus One X minus 1. now if we multiply
through by that common denominator the X
Plus One X minus 1 that clears the
denominators and we're just left with
the numerators so that's going to be x
minus 2 times x minus 1 which foils to x
squared minus 3x Plus 2.
equals 2x squared minus 2
minus 14. okay so we cleared the
denominators we just have the numerators
let's get everything on one side and set
it equal to zero so I'm going to
subtract x squared
from both sides I'm going to add 3x to
both sides
and I'm going to subtract 2 for both
sides
okay so that gives us 0 equals x squared
plus 3x
minus 18. and we can factor that
what multiplies to negative 18 but adds
to 3 that's going to be positive 6 and
negative 3. and then what we can do is
we can make two separate equations we
can say X plus 6 equals 0 and x minus 3
equals zero solve
so x equals negative 6 or x equals 3.
you want to make sure that you're not
dividing by zero it looks like as long
as X isn't one or negative 1 we're good
so it looks like we have two solutions
negative 6 or positive 3 and you got it
okay great job if you're still with me
we're halfway through this review so
let's keep going let's keep the momentum
now we're moving over to the unit circle
and we're evaluating some trig functions
at particular angles whether they're in
degrees or in radians so see if you can
refresh and test yourself on these six
problems go ahead and pause the video
and see if you can do these so for the
first one number 28 what's the cosine of
30 degrees well remember on the unit
circle the cosine is the x coordinate so
we would go to 30 degrees we'd say okay
the x coordinate is root 3 over 2 so the
cosine of 30 degrees is equal to square
root of 3 over 2 and you got it
for 29 what's the sine of pi over 3 well
remember whenever you see Pi Pi is equal
to 180 180 divided by 3 is 60. so we go
to our 60 degree angle and we want the
sine which remember the sine is the y
coordinate on the unit circle so again
we're getting square root 3 over 2.
for number 30 the tangent of 5 pi over
4. now when I see an improper fraction
like this I say well this is really like
1 and 1 4 Pi so what does that mean 1
and 1 4 Pi it means I'm going 1 Pi which
is 180 degrees plus another fourth of Pi
this would be 2 pi so 1 pi plus another
one fourth of Pi is going to put me
right here a drop of perpendicular to
the x-axis and I look at that reference
angle and I can see that it's uh 1 4 Pi
which is pi over 4 which is a 45 degree
angle that means that at this point the
coordinates are going to be the same as
the 45 but because we're in the third
quadrant and we're going left and down
both the X and the Y are negative so
negative root 2 over 2 negative root 2
over 2. remember the tangent is the y
coordinate divided by the x coordinate
anything divided by itself is going to
equal one so this is just going to come
out to 1.
for number 31 the secant of negative 210
degrees now remember when you go
counterclockwise this way that's a
positive angle when you go clockwise
this is actually a negative angle we
want to go negative 210 so this is 90
180 negative 210 we press somewhere
right about here
and that's a 30 degree reference angle
same as this 30 degree angle here in the
first quadrant but because we're in the
second quadrant the x is going to be
negative because you're going left and
the Y is positive now we want the secant
remember the secant is the reciprocal of
the cosine on the unit circle the cosine
is the x coordinate so we're just going
to take the reciprocal of that x
coordinate and let's just go ahead and
rationalize this to get rid of the
square root of 3 in the denominator and
this is coming out to negative 2 square
root of 3 over 3.
for number 32 the cosecant of 5 pi over
6. remember cosecant is the reciprocal
of sine sine is the Y on the unit circle
so the reciprocal of the y coordinate at
5 pi over 6. now 5 pi over 6 is like 5 6
of Pi Pi remember is like 180 we're
going 5 6 of the way which is right here
this is a reference angle of 1 6 Pi
which is the same as 30 degrees so we're
at the same location
but what we want to do is we want to
find the cosecant which is the
reciprocal of the sine or the Y value so
what's the reciprocal of one-half that's
just going to equal
2. and for the last one here number 33
the cotangent of 330 degrees
where is that well let's see that's
going to give you 180 270. this is 360.
so we're just 30 degrees shy of 360. so
that reference angle there is a 30
degree reference angle same as this one
but the y coordinate now is negative
because you're in the fourth quadrant
you're going right positive down
negative we want the cotangent the
tangent is the Y over X the cotangent is
the X over y so this is going to be the
square root 3 over 2 divided by negative
one half when you divide by a fraction
it's like multiplying by the reciprocal
you can see the twos are canceling on
the diagonal so we're getting a negative
square root of 3 for our cotangent of
330.
if you want more examples go to my
videos on mastering the unit circle if
you want to understand this a little bit
better
okay see if you can pause the video and
do number 34 and 35 and 34 we're
evaluating the six trig functions of
theta this angle here
and then for 35 we're solving the
triangle we're finding all the Angles
and all the sides so see if you can do
those two problems now for 34 if I was
solving this triangle or actually I'm
sorry evaluating the six trig functions
of this angle I need to find this
missing side here
so to do that we're going to use the
Pythagorean theorem we're going to say a
squared plus b squared equals c squared
so that's going to be 5 squared plus b
squared equals c squared so that comes
out to 25
plus b squared equals 100
B squared equals 75 take the square root
and 75 is 25 times 3 so that comes out
to 5 square root of 3. so that's this
missing side right here now we can use
our socatoa right our sine cosine and
tangent ratios to evaluate so we say
what's the sine of theta that's the
opposite over the hypotenuse so that's 5
over 10 which is equal to one half
the cosecant is the reciprocal of the
sine so we're just going to flip this
fraction over 2 over 1 which is 2.
if we want the cosine
that's the adjacent side over the
hypotenuse so Jason is next to the
hypotenuses across from the right angle
so that's going to give us 5 square root
of 3 over 10. the 5 and the 10 you can
reduce
that comes out to square root of 3 over
2. and the secant is the reciprocal of
the cosines if we take the reciprocal
this becomes 2 over square root of 3 we
can rationalize
by multiplying the top and bottom by
root 3 so that comes out to 2 square
root of 3 all over 3 and then for the
tangent the tangent is the opposite over
the adjacent so that comes out to 5 over
5 square root of 3. the 5S cancel so
that's one over root 3 and then if we
rationalize
that comes out to square root of 3 over
and the cotangent the reciprocal of the
tangent this was one over root 3 if I
take the reciprocal that's just root 3.
and you got it
now for number 35 solving the triangle
that means to find all the angles all
the sides so if I know that this angle
is 14 these two acute angles have to add
up to 90 Plus 90 is 180 so 90 minus 14
gives us 76 so angle D here is 76
degrees
and if I want to solve for let's say
side F here I'm going to go back to the
original angle and this side so I have
opposite and adjacent which is tangent
so the tangent of 14
degrees equals the opposite side F over
the adjacent side 12. multiply both
sides by 12 to get F by itself and let's
go to the calculator get an approximate
answer here make sure your calculator is
in degrees so 12 times the tangent of 14
is about 2.99 so that's the side right
here
and then if we want to solve for side e
let's see we've got adjacent and
hypotenuse that's cosine so I'd say the
cosine of 14 degrees
is equal to adjacent over hypotenuse now
you can cross multiply or multiply both
sides by e
and then here we can divide both sides
by cosine of 14 so e is equal to 12.
divided by the cosine of 14 degrees
let's see what that comes out to
and that one looks like it's about
12.37 so 12.37
and you solve the triangle all the
angles all the sides okay see if you can
pause the video and do number 36 37 and
38 on your own
for number 36 it says give one positive
angle and one negative angle that's
coterminal with pi over 9. so what does
that mean coterminal Co means same
terminal means where it terminates or
stops and if you think about an angle if
you add 360 Degrees that's like going
once around that unit circle you're
going to end up in the same spot or if
you subtract 360 you're going to go
around that unit circle and end up in
the same spot and those angles are going
to be coterminal but when you're in
radians like in this case here pi over 9
what we have to do is we have to add 2
pi which is equal to 360 degrees but in
radians and what we're going to have to
do is we're going to have to get a
common denominator so let's go ahead and
multiply the top and bottom here by nine
so this is 18 pi over 9 plus 1 pi over
9. that's 19 pi over 9. radians and then
if we want to do a negative angle we're
going to take pi over 9 minus
2 pi again multiply the numerator and
denominator by 9. so this is 1 Pi minus
18 Pi which is negative 17 pi over 9
radians and those are two possible
answers now for number 37 we're going to
convert from degrees to radians and 38
we're going to convert from radians to
degrees the important thing about this
problem is knowing the conversion factor
so how would you do this one well if I
was going to work through it through
this problem 40 degrees is like 40
degrees over one I'm going to multiply
by pi over 180 degrees notice the
degrees in the numerator cancels with
the degrees in the denominator leaving
us with pi radians right so pi and 180
are equal it's just that you're using
this as a unit conversion factor so we
multiply horizontally across here we're
getting 40 pi over 180 we can reduce by
dividing by 10. and divide by 2
numerator and denominator and you can
see we're getting 2 pi over 9 radians
and then for 38 going the other
direction from radians to degrees
let's start with the 5 pi over 12 but
we're going to multiply by the
reciprocal now 180 degrees over Pi this
way the pi radians cancel numerator and
denominator and then if we multiply
horizontally across that's one way to do
it we can also do some cross reducing
here
12 goes into 12 once 12 goes into 180 15
times 5 times 15 is 75 1 times 1 is 1
anything divided by 1 is itself so we
get 75 degrees for that one
okay see if you can pause the video and
do number 39 and 40. 39 deals with
finding the arc length and 40 deals with
finding the area of a sector so go ahead
and try those problems for number 39 it
says find the arc length of a circle
with central angle 120 degrees and a
diameter of 10 inches so let's draw a
picture here just so we can visualize we
have a central angle of 120 degrees so
approximately like this and the diameter
is 10 which means that the radius would
be like 5. so how do we find this
curved portion here of the circle this
Arc Length well we know the
circumference is
2 pi r or pi times diameter so in this
case pi times 10 is giving us the whole
circumference but what we want is just
the fraction of the whole circumference
we just want 120 divided by
360. this is actually one-third so you
can see this arc length is one third of
our whole circumference here so let's go
ahead and reduce this down a little bit
so this is 1 over 3 and this is like
over one and if I multiply across here
this gives us 10 pi over 3 inches and
that's an exact answer for this arc
length
now for number 40 a very similar type of
situation where you're finding the area
of a sector with central angle 5 pi over
6 and radius 4 centimeters so let's draw
a picture here 5 pi over 6 is roughly
like this
and here's a radius of 4
centimeters and we're trying to find the
area
now okay so what we can do is we can
think about the area of the whole circle
which is pi r squared so that's pi times
4 squared but what we want is the
fraction of the whole circle so this is
going to be 5 pi over 6
divided by 2 pi which is 360 degrees
so now we can simplify a little bit you
can see the pi in the numerator Pi in
the denominator those are going to
cancel here we get 16 pi
and here we get 5 12. so this is like
multiplying by 5 12. so we can reduce
down a little bit further 4 goes into 12
3 times 4 goes into 16 four times
so this is coming out to 20 pi over 3
centimeters squared and that's the area
of the sector so just think about the
area and then the fraction of that whole
area
okay see if you can pause the video and
do number 41 and 42 for 41 it says the
Leaning Tower of Pisa is approximately
184.5 feet above the ground at its
Center
and it leans at an angle of four degrees
from the vertical
if it could be completely straightened
what would be its New Height okay so how
would you do that problem well if we
were to draw a picture like let's just
say that this represents the tower okay
it's leaning like this and it's four
degrees
from the vertical like that and here
it's telling us that it's a
184.5 feet above the ground at the
center of the tower but what we're
wanting to do now is we're wanting to
basically straighten that Tower right
now assuming that you know this doesn't
sink into the ground but you could just
like pivot it like this we're actually
looking for the hypotenuse of this
triangle
so if this is a four degree angle this
must be at 86 degrees because that adds
up to 90 like a right angle and we have
to ask ourselves what trig function sine
cosine or tangent ties together this
angle this side and this side well we've
got opposite and hypotenuse that's the
sine
so we would say the sine of 86 degrees
is equal to the opposite side
over the hypotenuse so I'll just call
this X and then you can cross multiply
or there's another technique of
proportions where you can interchange
these on the diagonal
x divided by 1 is just X and so that's
going to be 184.5 divided by the sine of
86 make sure your calculator is in
degrees
and let's see what that comes out to so
184.5 divided by the sine of 86 I'm
getting almost 185 so we'll just say
approximately 185
feet and that's your answer now for
number 42 we want to graph this sine
graph and we also want to State the
amplitude and the period so this number
here in front
is going to be like our vertical stretch
that's our amplitude it's always going
to be positive if it's negative you just
take the absolute value to get the
amplitude so that's 6.
and now for the period this one half
it's going to have the reciprocal effect
on the period when it's grouped with the
X like that it's going to have the
reciprocal effect so that means instead
of being the period of normally 2 pi for
sine it's going to be 2 pi times 2 which
is 4 Pi if you want a formula some
students use this Formula 2 pi divided
by B and this is like your B value so
you'd say 2 pi divided by one-half when
you divide by a fraction it's like
multiplying by the reciprocal so that's
where we're getting our period of 4 Pi
now what I would do is I would divide
this up into 4 equal pieces here and so
that means our scale on the x-axis is
going to be pi
2 pi 3 Pi 4 pi and when we graph our
sine graph it starts at this midline
here it goes to the maximum back to the
midline down to the minimum back to the
midline
and you can draw a nice smooth curve now
if you want a more General way of
writing this just so you can kind of see
it looks like a
a sine b x minus h plus K so the H
shifts it left and right the K shifts it
up and down the one group of the X has
the opposite effect and again we've got
our amplitude and the B is related to
the period by this formula here 2 pi
over B if you forget about the basic
graph you can always go back to your
unit circle remember these key points
here at 0 90 180 and 270
and then what you can do is sine is the
y coordinate so see how we're starting
at zero then it goes to 1 which would be
like your maximum then back to zero
which is like your midline negative one
is your minimum and then back to zero is
your midline here it's being stretched
by a factor of six okay see if you can
pause the video and graph number 43 and
44 the cosine and the tangent graph
so this one y equals negative 2 cosine
two times the quantity X plus pi over 4
minus 1. how would you graph that and
you want to label the amplitude the
period the horizontal shift and the
vertical shift well the amplitude we can
see it's going to be the absolute value
of negative 2 which is 2.
and we can see that the period is going
to be 2 pi divided by 2 which is pi
the horizontal shift is going to be left
pi over 4.
remember the one group of the X has the
opposite effect so we'll say left pi
over 4 and then the vertical shift minus
1 means it's going to go down one
okay so now if we want to graph this we
know our period is pi so let's go ahead
and
divide this up into four pieces or a
scale on the x axis is going to be pi
over 4.
and let's see this is going to be
negative pi over 4 if we go to the left
and then we can one two three one two
three and let's see we're going to shift
left pi over 4 and down one so what
we're going to do is we're going to
think of this point right here as our
new origin basically everything is
Shifting left pi over 4 down 1. so I'm
just going to draw in some new like X
and Y axes then we're going to graph the
cosine graph from this point with an
amplitude of 2 the negative reflects it
over that
x-axis right so in this case what's
going to happen is we're going to start
Down 2 right here
okay below this new origin we're going
to go back to the midline
then we're going to go up to the maximum
see two above back to the midline and
then
down here to below so that's going to
give us one period
of our cosine graph and then you can
repeat it from there
okay so for number 44 we're graphing
this tangent graph and we want to talk
about what is the period the vertical
stretch and the horizontal shift
well in this case you can see the
vertical stretch is going to be 3
the horizontal shift is going to be
right one
and the period now for tangent the
period is normally Pi so we can use the
formula instead of 2 pi over b 1 pi over
B this is our B value pi over 2 so
that's pi divided by pi over 2 when you
divide by a fraction it's like
multiplying by the reciprocal so this is
just coming out to a period of two now
the way the tangent graph looks our
basic paragraph half the graph is to the
left
of the y axis of half is to the right so
I would take this period 2 and I would
make this like negative 1 positive one
that gives me a period of two so on my
scale here I'm going to count by one so
I'm going to say one two three and we'll
go this direction negative three and
what we're going to do now is we're
going to shift right one so we're going
to think of this as our new
like starting point and then our period
we know is 2 so I can go right one and
left one this is going to be our new
location of our asymptotes right here
and our tangent graph goes up to the
right unless it's been reflected
and it's being stretched by a factor of
three so that's going to be one two
three this is going to put us right
halfway that we can draw on some halfway
points this is 1.5 this is 0.5 so this
is going to put us at 3 0 and negative
3. and that gives us one period or one
cycle of our tangent graph and you can
repeat it again in both directions okay
go ahead and pause the video see if you
can do number 45 46 and 47 for number 45
given the equation of y equals cosine X
what is the domain and the range of that
graph well we talked about how to graph
cosine graph a little bit earlier okay
in this review and remember how cosine
basically looks like this and it keeps
repeating the domain is what the X
values can be so you can see it goes to
the right and the left forever and ever
so we would say the domain is all real
numbers or you could say negative
Infinity to positive Infinity if you're
working in interval notation the range
you can see it's going between negative
1 and positive one that's the possible y
value so we would write that as negative
1 is less than or equal to Y is less
than or equal to 1.
for number 46 now we're going to write
an equation of y equals sine X with an
amplitude of 2 a period of 8 Pi
reflected over the x-axis shifts in left
2 pi and down one so how would you write
that equation see if you can try that
one well I'd probably start with the
period here of 8 pi and remember that
formula we talked about earlier P equals
2 pi over B so if the period is 8 pi
you can multiply both sides by B
and then divide both sides by 8 pi
and you can see this reduces down to 1
4. so in our equation our B value is
going to be 1 4. our amplitude is two
that's our a values remember we're
working with this basic equation a sine
b x minus h plus k
and so we have our amplitude of 2. it's
being reflected over the x-axis so this
is going to be a negative 2
the B value we already figured out is 1
4.
it's shifting to the left 2 pi so this
is going to be X plus 2 pi remember the
one group of the X has the opposite
effect so plus 2 pi is going left 2 pi
if it was minus 2 pi It Go Right 2 pi
and then we're shifting down one that's
this K value minus one this has the same
effect negative is down positive is up
and you got your equation
for number 47 it says given that the
cosine of theta is negative 7 over 25
and the angle Theta is between pi and 3
pi over 2. how would you find the sine
of theta and the tangent of theta
go ahead and pause the video see if you
can do that one if I was going to do
this I'd probably draw a sketch like
this I'd say well I'm from PI to 3 pi
over 2. that puts me over here in the
third quadrant
okay and if I focus on the central angle
here the cosine is the adjacent
over the hypotenuse
and if I do the Pythagorean theorem a
squared plus b squared equals c squared
this is going to come out to 24 but
because it's in the third quadrant
you're going down that's going to be a
negative 24. this is a Pythagorean
triple 7 24 25 but you can do the
Pythagorean theorem and then the sign is
the opposite over hypotenuse so that's
going to give us a negative 24 over 25
and the tangent is the opposite over
adjacent which is going to give us 24
over 7 the two negatives cancel and give
us a positive
so good job if you were able to get that
one
okay see if you can pause the video and
do number 48 49 and 50 and while you're
doing that I just want to mention that
if you like the way that I'm explaining
things and you want to go deeper with
learning more about Algebra 2 I've got
an Algebra 2 video course for sale it's
in the description below if you want to
check that out also if you'd like to
just support the videos that I'm putting
up here on my Mars math tutoring YouTube
channel consider becoming a channel
member for a few dollars a month you can
help support the channel and I really
appreciate that and lastly if you are
interested I also have some t-shirts for
sale on my Teespring store so if you
just want to support the channel and
support what I'm doing here consider
purchasing one of those t-shirts but
let's dive back into these problems here
now so for 48 it says six people stand
in a line for a photo and how many ways
can they stand for the photo
now there's a couple different ways to
do this one way is just to diagram it
out there are six people like this right
and you say how many people can stand in
this first position well you've got six
choices for who stands furthest to the
left
but once that person stands there now
there's only five people that can fight
over who's going to stand in the second
position and down four three two one you
can also write this as six factorial
that's what the exclamation point
represents there 654321 and that's going
to come out to
720 different ways to stand for this
photo
for number 49
it says how many license plates are
there with four numbers followed by
three digits if the letters can repeat
but the digits cannot repeat so how
would you do that one
well with the digits there's 26 letters
in the English alphabet and it says that
the uh can repeat so that means there's
26 choices for the first letter 26 for
the second third and fourth now I'm
using the same number because you've got
26 choices you can reuse those letters
right but with the numbers you can have
zero through nine that's actually ten
different digits but you can't repeat so
it's going to go down by one each time
so if you multiply all of these together
that's going to give you the total
number of license plates different
license plates so 26 times 26
okay times 10 times 9 times 8 I'm
getting a 3 2 9 0 2 2 7 2 0. so that's
329 million 22 720 different license
plates and for number 50 it says find
the number of distinguishable
permutations of the word mathematics
so how would you do that one how many
different ways are there to arrange the
letters in the words mathematics such
that it makes like a new word using all
of those letters well if I was going to
do this one one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven so there's
11 factorial ways of arranging 11 items
but because we have two M's we're going
to divide out by two factorial and we've
got two A's
2 factorial
and we have two T's
two factorial anything else repeated now
if there was three A's a divide by three
factorial or four A's four factorial so
we're dividing out the multiplicities
because if you interchange these two M's
for example you'd still have the same
word mathematics and it wouldn't be a
distinguishable permutation so let's go
to the calculator on this one let's see
so we have 11 factorial
okay
divided by two factorial which is 2
times 1 2 factorial two times one two
factorial two times one that comes out
to eight so this is coming out to four
nine eight nine six zero zero so there's
almost five million different
distinguishable permutations okay see if
you can pause the video and do number 51
52 and 53 on your own 51 says you're
forming a math club of seven members in
your class of 30 students how many
possible combinations are there
now there's a little bit of a hint in
this problem they mentioned combinations
right which really refers to the fact
that the order doesn't matter it's not
like you have a president of the math
club and a vice president secretary
treasurer so if the order doesn't really
matter in this case we're going to use
this formula NCR and remember NCR is
saying out of n items how many ways are
there to choose R where the order
doesn't matter so the formula here is n
factorial Over N minus r factorial times
R factorial
so in this case what we have is going to
be 30
see
7 which is 30 factorial over 30 minus 7
which is 23 factorial times R factorial
which is 7 factorial you can also use
this combination key on your calculator
we could just do 30 C
7 but if you want to show your work
that's what you would show and then you
can see this is coming out to
203-5800 so that's two million thirty
five thousand eight hundred different
ways to make a group of seven people out
of 30 where the order doesn't matter
for number 52 this one says of a Hundred
bicycle Racers how many ways are there
to award a gold silver and bronze medal
to the first second and third place
finishers
well in this case what's interesting
about this problem is the order does
matter because if you change person a b
and c to c b and a you're going to get a
different metal being awarded to each
one of those bicycle Racers so in this
case the order is important which means
we're going to want to use a permutation
NPR and remember the formula for NPR is
n factorial Over N minus r factorial so
in this case it would be out of 100 how
many ways are there to pick
3 where the order is important or the
order matters so it would be 100
factorial over 100 minus 3 which is 97
factorial
and if you wanted to do this by hand 100
factorial is 100 times 99 times 98 times
97 all the way down to 1. 97 factorial
is 97 times 96 times 95 all the way down
to one so these are going to cancel all
the way down to 1 and you're just left
with 100 times 99 times 98 which is
970 200 different ways to assign a first
second and third place or gold silver
bronze
notice the other way to look at this is
there's a hundred ways that somebody
could finish first once that person
finishes first there's 99 people that
can then compete for the silver metal
and then once those two there's only 90
left to compete for bronze so that's
using the fundamental counting principle
this is using the permutations and for
number 53 how would you do this one it
says find the coefficient
of x to the fifth in the expansion of
this binomial x minus 3 to the seventh
power
well this one you see when they talk
about the coefficient they just want the
number in front of this particular term
now you could expand this out using
Pascal's triangle that's one option but
it would take a little bit of work to do
that so there's a little bit of a
shortcut I'll see if I can kind of show
you uh let's see you've got X is your
first term negative 3 is your second
term in your binomial we want to make
sure this is to the fifth
power that means this has to be the
second power these are always going to
add up to 7 which is the row or the
power of the binomial then we this is a
combination so this is going to be
7c2 so this second terms exponent and
this r value they're always going to
match these two exponents are always
going to add up to 7 or whatever the
power or the row is all we have to do
now is simplify negative 3 squared is 9
x to the fifth is X to the fifth seven
combination 2 is how much
that's 21 so this is 21 times 9 which is
189 x to the fifth we just want the
coefficient just the number in front of
the variable so it would just be 189.
okay see if you can do these last two
problems on your own and we'll go
through them together and I just wanted
to say if you enjoyed this lesson and
you want to kind of go deeper and talk
more about uh getting ready for the
algebra 2 final exam whether it's for
the first semester or the second
semester I have two other uh
comprehensive videos like this one where
I go through and review some of those
important problems for that test so
check out those videos on my Mars math
tutoring YouTube channel but let's dive
into 54 now it says expand 2x minus 5 to
the fourth power so how would you do
that one well one way to do this is to
use Pascal's triangle so you could say
one one
one two one one three three one one four
six four one I'm going down to this
fourth row remember this starts at row 0
1 2 3 4. these represent uh
our coefficients here so I'm going to
write it in a vertical fashion one four
six four one
we're going to take that first term
which is 2x to the fourth power and
we're going to go in descending order so
2x to the third 2x to the second 2x to
the first and 2x to the zero and we're
going to take that second term negative
five remember if it's a minus that's a
negative and we're going to start at
zero and we're going to go in ascending
order
so this is kind of refreshing you here
on the binomial expansion
this is a quick way of doing it and then
now what we're going to do is we're
going to simplify each of these terms so
we've got
2 to the fourth is 16 x to the fourth
negative 5 to the 0 is 1. so this first
term comes out to
16 x to the fourth
here we have 2 cubed is eight
times four is 32 times negative 5 is
negative 160.
x to the third remember follow the order
of operations parentheses exponents then
multiplication so 2 squared is four
negative 5 squared is 25 so 4 times 25
is 100 times 6 is going to give us 600 x
squared 2 to the first is 2 negative 5
cubed is a negative 125 2 times negative
125 is negative 250 times 4 is negative
a thousand x to the first
anything to zero is one negative 5 to
the fourth is a positive
625. if you wanted to write this in a
horizontal fashion we have 16x to the
fourth minus 160x cubed
plus 600 x squared minus a thousand X
Plus 625
and that's fully expanded 2x minus 5 to
the fourth okay so for the last problem
number 55
your free throw scoring percentage is
eighty percent if you take eight free
throws what is the probability that you
make exactly five of those free throws
and the second part is you make at least
one of those free throws let's start
with making exactly five so this is what
they call binomial probability it's like
success or failure win or lose right and
so in this case we'd say all right we
want to make out of eight we want to
make exactly five the probability of
making the basket is eighty percent
we're looking for five of those missing
that's one minus 0.80 or 20 percent we
want three of those so if we go to the
calculator now let's see what this comes
out to
okay let me just do this real quick
I'm getting uh let's see approximately
0.15 so basically it's a fifteen percent
uh probability that you're going to make
exactly five of those free throws now at
least one there's a little trick you can
do with this at least one at least one
means the one which is a hundred percent
minus the probability that you make none
of them so one minus the probability of
none is one or more at least one so
let's do that so the probability that
you make zero would be out of eight free
throws you're going to score zero of
them the probability of scoring we want
zero of those and the probability of
missing that's 20 percent we want eight
of those so let's see what this is and
we're going to do one minus that so 8C 0
is
1.80 to the 0 is 1. so 0.2 to the eighth
point zero zero zero zero zero
two let's see one two three four five
two five six and one minus that
is 0.999
744 let's see do I have 29s here let's
see three four five seven four four okay
so basically as far as the probability
you could say this is the probability if
you wanted to write it as a percentage
this would be basically like 99.99 that
you make at least one so great job if
you made it all the way through this
review leave a comment if you were able
to go through this whole review and let
me know how you did and again if you
want more practice follow me over to
this other Algebra 2 final exam review
that I did previously I'll see you over
in that video and good luck on your exam